[Music]
good god is it cold is it freezing out
there or what that's it
yes it's unbelievable out there in Los
Angeles just want to clap for warm I
know no get this it's so cold this
morning Lindsay Lohan intentionally
crashed her car into a blanket store
covered herself up oh this is better
yeah
now these are record cold temperatures
were having in Los Angeles
yeah the city is almost as cold as the
Lakers starting five I'm not from this
town I'm not from this town did you say
cold or old cuz it works either way
this is the new formula for the show I
come out alienate the audience right up
top no I know but people are talking
about like oh it got that we were
talking with this last night oh it was
61 last night I shot myself yeah
unbelievable yeah what else is going on
everybody waiting for that Oprah Winfrey
Lance Armstrong interview who's wooing
that it's not something you would let us
all bow yeah
[Applause]
you shattered our illusion the integrity
of sport yeah those were terrible chance
[Laughter]
notices last Oprah Winfrey says she
conducted quote an intense two and a
half hour interview with Lance Armstrong
two and a half hours Oprah said she
never would have had the stamina if
Lance hadn't given her a little
something to keep going
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
that's real right there that's where I
get mine I've been juicing for years
President Obama struggling with the debt
ceiling that's always a fun comedy
premise brenes know President Obama told
Congress it must raise our debt limit
because the u.s. is quote not a deadbeat
nation yeah then the president added by
the way if China calls I'm not here I'm
still here yesterday quiet
yesterday yesterday Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas spoke during a
court session for the first time in
seven years he never speaks he finally
spoke yeah it's already being called the
best that's what she said joke ever
Walmart made a big announcement Walmart
announced plans to hire 100,000 US
veterans
[Music]
which can only mean one thing Walmart is
going to invade Costco to kick the crap
out a survivalist group is trying to
build a gated community which would
house up to 7,000 like-minded families
yeah they're calling this conservative
compound Orange County I am NOT from
here the makers I don't we have any Star
Wars fans here but the nacre
haven't I alienated you enough
who likes Star Wars I do yeah well ha
[Music]
the makers of a Star Wars videogame are
now introducing a new version that
features a gay planet yeah also now the
game begins with the words a long time
ago like so last week in a new interview
it's funny when I suddenly get sad in a
new interview actress Megan Fox compared
fame to being bullied in high school
yeah I agree
I'll never forget that day in high
school when jocks cornered me in the gym
and paid me millions of dollars to star
in transformers
[Applause]